[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الخلافات والانقسامات
وتتوسع يوما بعد يوم داخل صفوف جامعه
الاخوان اخرها انقسام بسبب كتاب في ظلال
القران لمنظر التنظيم سيد قطب والذي تضمنا
مشروع الجماعه ومنهجها الحركي حيث اعلن
القيد الاخواني الهارب الى تركيا عصام
تليمه اعاده نشر الطبعه الاولى من كتاب في
ظلال القران وهي النسخه التي تم اعاده
طبعها مرات متعدده واضافه اجزاء كثيره لها
ضمت افكار قطب عن الحاكميه وعن الجاهليه
وعن التكفير ايضا والعزله الشعوريه وهو
مراته قياده الاخوان محاوله للتنصل من
افكار سيد قطب واظهار الجماعه وكانها نسبت
له ما لم يقلها وتعاملت معه كم منهج تنظيم
وحركيا لها كما يرى التيار الثالث داخل
الجماعه والمعروف باسم الكماليون نسبه
لمحمد كمال ان الكتابه يقف وراءها تيار
جديد يحاول فالجماعه وتحويلها لتيار فكري
كتاب في ظلال القران لسيد قطب يقع الكتاب
في 30 جزءا مجموعه في ست مجلدات قصه
الكتاب تعود للنهايات الاربعين حين بدا
قطب اعداد الكتابي بطلب من مجله المسلمون
اضاف قطب المنهج الحركي لجماعه الاخوان
اليه وهو الكتاب النهائي الذي اصبح منهجا
ودستورا للجماعه الى اليوم
[موسيقى]
الموضوع من القاهره مع احمد بان الباحث في
شؤون الجماعات المتطرفه من القاهره مع
منير اديب الباحث في شؤون الحركه المتطرفه
والارهاب الدولي مرحبا بكما ضيفيا
الكريمين استاذ احمد بان كتاب في ظلال
القران يثير انقساما الان بعد اكثر من 80
عاما على اصداره الطبعه الجديده يبدو انها
تثير انقساما بين الاخوان لماذا هذا
الكتاب الذي عمره ثمانيه عقود يثير هذا
الانقسام الان بين الاخوان
تحيه لكم استاذ صهيب بطبيعه الحال لا يمكن
فصل الجدل حول طبعات كتاب في ظلال القران
الكريم بين طبعه اولى وطبعا ثانيا بين
افكار وردت في الطبعه الاولى ثم يحاولون
التنصل منها في طبعات لاحقه نحن لا يمكننا
ان نفصل ما يجري عن الخلاف داخل تنظيم
الاخوان بين مجموعتين هما بالاساس يمثلان
ما يسمى بالطيار القطبي وبالتالي وبالتالي
هذا التيار الذي يتقاسم الايمان
بالايدلوجيه القطبيه التي همم اختارها
التنظيم منذ
منتصف الخمسينات وحتى همم وقت همم
متاخر الان بعدما تحولت هذه الايديولوجيا
من لم تعد حكرا على تنظيم الاخوان بل
اصبحت منافذته التط والارهاب لكل
المجموعات اللي ظهرت بعد بعد
من الاخوان يريد التنصل من الاجزاء التي
كتبها سيد قطب وهو في السجن بمعنى وهي
التي عرفت الكثير من مسائل العنف يعني ترى
ان هناك فصيل من الاخوان ان يريد التنصل
من من الجانب التكفيري والجانب الذي يدعو
لحمل السلاح ووو القتال هذا ما يحصل
تحديدا تحديدا جبهه ابراهيم منير تحاول
عبر عصام كلينما ان تقدم قراءه جديده
لافكار سيد قطب اعتمادا على النسخه الاولى
او الطبعه الاولى لهذا الكتاب الذي حاولت
ان تتنصل فيه من حموله كبيره تتحدث عن
الاستعلاء الايماني تتحدث عن العزله
الشعوريه تتحدث عن الحاكميه تتحدث عن
الجاهليه لك ان تتخيل ان مصطلح الجاهليه
ورد في كتاب الظلال 550 مره همم مصطلح
الحاكميه همم تردد 77 مره وبالتالي يعني
جهد كبير في همم اكتساب هذه الافكار لا
يمكن ابدا ان ينتج شيئا في الواقع هم
ينقلون من مناقشه الافكار الى مناقشه
الطبعات او الجدل حول الطبعات لكن في
حقيقه الامر لم يناقش احد همم حقيقه افكار
سيد قطب التي انبتت كل هذه التنظيمات التي
ملات حياتنا عنفا وارهابا على مدار عقود
التي اصابت حتى تصور المجتمعات عن الاسلام
بتشوه وهي لم تؤثر على مصر فقط بل امتدت
الى كل العالم العربي والعالم يعني
الحقيقه همم استاذ منير اديب اجدد الترحيب
بك اهلا بك معنا هل تتفق مع الاستاذ احمد
بان سبب الخلاف الان بين الاخوان حول كتاب
سيد قطب في ظلال القران هو رغبه همم فصيل
الممثل همم بتليمه همم بانه يريد ان يحذف
الاجزاء المتعلقه بالعنف من الكتاب
اهلا وسهلا بك يا استاذ صهيب وبكل مشاهدي
العربيه وبضيفك الكريم الاستاذ احمد
وليسمح لي يعني بان يختلف معه قليلا يعني
في تقديري الخاص نحن لا نتحدث عن مدرستين
داخل التنظيم المدرسه القطبيه التي تحمل
افكار سيد قطب المنظر
الرئيسي لهذه الحركه او المؤسس الثاني
للتنظيم بعد حسن البنا ومدرسه اخرى هي كما
يقول الاخوان هي مدرسه الدعوه اولئك الذين
يريدون ان يمارسوا الدعوه دون ااا اي تصور
للعنف او حتى ببعض تصورات العنف في
اعتقادي وفي تقديرها الخاص انه هناك طيار
عام داخل الاخوان المسلمين وهو الطيار
القطبي وهو يمثل النواه الصلبه لحركه
الاخوان المسلمين صحيح الصالح حسن البنا
لافكار العنف ولكن هذه الافكار بات لها
اقدام ربما على يد
حاسه سيد قطب وبالتالي انا اساس اساس
الفكر يعني هو سيد قطب يعني ليس هناك تيار
قطبي وتيار غير قطبي في الاخوان لانه
بالاساس سيد قطب هو الاساس في الفكره
الاخوان
نعم بدليل ان سيد قطب كان له حيثيه
تنظيميه كان عضو لمكتب الارشاد وكان
مسؤولا عن لجان التربيه داخل مكتب الارشاد
ولجان التربيه هذه هي المنضود بها همم
يعني همم
نشر الوعي وهمم اقامه ما يمكن ان يسميه
بالعقل الاخواني اذا هو كان له حيثيا بهذه
الافكار ومن ثم عندما مات سيد قطب لم
يتبرا الاخوان ولم يعتذروا عن افكار سيد
قطب لم يتراجعوا عن هذه الافكار في
اعتقادي ان همم
هو مجرد صوت نشاز داخل الاخوان ولذلك كل
الاخوان يريدون افكار سيد قطب عندما تبحث
عن كتب سيد قطب سواء في ظلال القران او
همم هذا الدين او غيرها من الكتب التي
خطاها سيد قطب كلها تدرس داخل الاسر
التربويه للاخوان بما يعني ان الاخوان في
حاله رضاء عام وكبير على افكار سيد قطب
عصامه اليمه لديه مشكله وهنا دعني اقول لك
ان مشكله عصام تليمه مع سيد قطب ليس لها
علاقه بالافكار لا من قريب ولا من بعيد هي
لها علاقه بان هذه الافكار حمالات التنظيم
ما لا يحتمل وبالتالي وضعته امام اتهامات
كثيره لها علاقه بالعنف ولذلك همم ما زلت
اكرر ان التيار العام داخل التنظيم هو
الطيار همم قطبي
والكل يؤيد افكار سيد قطب وسلطه ايضا ان
انه لم تخرج لم تخرج من من داخل الاخوان
اي مراجعات خاصه بافكار سيد قطب سواء
العزله الشعوريه او همم مفاهيم الجاهليه
والحاكميه نعم استاذ احمد كيف ترد الاستاذ
منير اديب يختلف معك قليلا انه ليس هناك
يعني تيارين في في الاخوان بل انه التيار
ال- ال- ال- ال- الاساسي هو تيار سيد قطب
لانه يعتبر هو منظر همم الجماعه الاساسي
قليلا مع التاريخ يعني تاريخ هذا التنظيم
الذي يكاد يلامس الان قرن من الزمان قبل
همم بدا قبل ان ينضم سيد قطب للتنظيم سيد
قطب تاريخيا لم يكن عضوا في مكتب الارشاد
ولم يتولى اي مناصب اداريه داخل التنظيم
هو الطلعه باداره قسم نشر الدعوه ولم اا
يباشر اي مهام تربويه داخل الصف بل ا- بدا
في مساله التربيه والتنظير لافكاره في
العام 65 حتى حتى فتره قضيه 65 لم يكن
لديه لم نكن امام تمايز للتيار القطبي
داخل الجماعه هذا التميز بدا لاحقا في ما
يسمى بازمه ب 65 لكن قبل ذلك كان المنظر
الاول حسن البنا هو الذي نظر لكل افكار
التنظيم ولا زال هو المنظر الاول هناك
دائما داخل تنظيم الاخوان كنا امام
اتجاهين من يحسبون على تنظيم حسن البنا او
افكار حسن البنا وفي القلب منهم او اكثر
من عبر عنهم كان يوسف القرضاوي شيخ عصام
تلمي» الذي اكد على وجود هذه الافكار
التكفيريه وحاول ان ينزل حسن البنا وينزه
جماعه الاخوان من هذه الافكار في كتابه
ابن القريه وبالتالي فكره التميز همم
الفكري ربما هو تميز شكلي بالنظر الى ان
همم المجموعتين يحاولان صنع هدف واحد او
الوصول الى هدف
واحدد
شكل الدوله والوصول الى ما يسمى بالخلافه
الاسلاميه لكن كنا امام وجه هادئ يمثله
حسن البنا يحاول ان يكون اكثر مكرا في همم
التغلغل داخل المجتمع بينما كان سيد قطب
اكثر صفورا في الحديث عن افكار العزله
الشعريه والمفاصله مع المجتمع ومع السلطه
نحن لا ندعي هنا او لا نختلف مع صديقنا
منير حول فكره ان الافكار تغيرت الافكار
واحده التيار القطبي يسيطر على التنظيم
منذ السبعينيات وحتى الان لكن ما قبل
السبعينيات لم يكن همم سيطره قطبيه بشكل
واضح وانما حدث لاحقا لكن هذا التميز كما
اسلفت لا ينفي جميل جدا الى نقطه مهمه جدا
همم الاستاذ احمد وصلنا الى النقطه اردت
ان اسالك عنها هل يريد عصام تليمه اذا
العوده الى نهج حسن البنا في تنظيم
الاخوان وهو التغلغل برفق يعني التخلي عن
الصدام وعن التكفير وعن القتل ويعني
العداء للدوله المدنيه وعدم المشاركه في
السياسه ويذهب باتجاه البراغماتيه
السياسيه انه بهدف الوصول الى الحكم دعونا
نتغلغل برفق
ونتخلى عن افكار سيد قطب التي كتبها في
السجن والتي تدعو للعنف والصدار
اذا كان ذلك
فصح ما قلته انه تناول هذه الافكار من
وجهه نظر سياسيه وليس من وجهه نظر فكريه
او فقيه اذا هو يرى ان هذه الافكار باتت
عبئا على التنظيم هو يريد ان يتخفف منها
ما الفرق ما بين ما طرحه سيد قطب وكان
يدعو الى تجهيل المجتمع وتكفيره ومن ثم
ممارسه العمق باسم القتال في سبيل الله او
حتى الجهاد في سبيل الله وهي نفس الافكار
التي طرحها حسن البنا عندما انشا ذراعا
عسكريا للاخوان او ما سمعه هو وقتها
النظام الخاص اذا هذا عنف وهذا عنف عندما
نتحدث على ان هناك مدرسه لحسن البنا وهناك
مدرسه لسيد قطب وكاننا نعترف ربما في طيات
الكلام ان تمت اختلاف ما بين مدرستين او
ان هناك من يريد ان يمارس عنفا واخر ربما
يمارس همم العنف ولكن بشكل فيه اا مدراء
همم في تقديري الخاص همم هم مدرسه واحده
ربما يكون حسن البنا طرح افكارا ولكن هذه
الافكار تعامل معها بشكل حركي همم سيد قطب
ولذلك سيد قطب همم في وجهه نظره اا تاثيره
همم جاء من صلاحيته هو وجودي وكان يمثل
رمزا كبيرا ومهما داخل حركه الاخوان
المسلمين يعني اقول ولست مبالغا انه قاد
التنظيم بعد حسن البنا وهو تنظيم 65
وبالتالي كان قائدا لتنظيم وكان ايضا
مؤصلا للافكار التي مارس التنظيم من
خلالها العمق في عهد وبعد مماته وحتى هذه
اللحظه طيب استاذ احمد اختم معك في سؤال
اخير انت صاحب كتاب قواعد الفكر الاخواني
الاربع
انا لدي سؤال هنا هل يمكن في يوم من
الايام ان تعود جماعه الاخوان او فكر
الجماعه الى العمل السياسي همم ان همم
تحصل فيها مراجعات فكريه ان تتخلى عن
العنف وتقتنع بمساله همم العمل السياسي
وان تكون جزءا من نسيج الديمقراطيات
العربيه او في العالم ام هذا مستبعد تماما
وفقما ذكرته في قواعد الفكر الاخوان
الاربعه
للاسف هذا لونه ان التفكير بالتمني نحن
امام تنظيمات لم تضبط متلبسه بمراجعه
افكارها ولن تقوى على مراجعه افكارها لان
مراجعه هذه الافكار يعني كشف هذا الفكر
امام عناصره التي اعتنقته لعقود اا طويله
هذا فكر غير قابل للتعويم هذه الجماعه او
هذا التنظيم استكمل اطوار حياته ولا اظن
ان يعبر الى قرن همم قادم هذه افكار غير
قابله للحياه خاصمت ليس فقط كل انواع
الانظمه السياسيه ملكيه وجمهوريه وغيرها
لكنها خاصمت المجتمعات بالاساس صمت التسوق
اكثر سماحه للدين وبالتالي لم يعد
بالامكان تعاونها من جديد والله الحقيقه
الحوار معكم شيق جدا والموضوع يتحمل اكثر
من ذلك نتمنى ان تكون لنا فرص اخرى كيف
نناقشه بشكل همم اكثر همم طولا همم بشكل
مطول اكثر شكرا جزيلا لكما من القاهره
احمد الباحث في شؤون الجماعات المتطرفه
ومن القاهره منير اديب البحث في شؤون
الحركات المتطرفه والارهاب الدولي